et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
bruno meier feld bonjour et bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes le
correspondant du monde au brésil vous
signez cauchemar brésilien qui sort
aujourd'hui chez grasset merci nous ont
réservé la primeur le cauchemar s'est
lui jaillir ball sonar au président
brésilien depuis quatre ans qu'il est
encore pendant quelques semaines
incroyables photos que celle que vous
avez choisi pour cette nous sommes le 7
7 7 septembre c'est aujourd'hui le
bicentenaire de l'indépendance du brésil
qui était une colonie portugaise
jusqu'en 2008 122 gm golden arrow a
appelé ses partisans à se rassembler en
masse ils avaient fait pareil l'année
dernière et la journée avait été
extrêmement tendue avec un assaut sur la
cour suprême notamment repoussé in
extremis c'est ce qu'on s'attend à une
journée sous haute tension ah oui tout à
fait il n'y a pas de raison de penser
qu'aujourd'hui pourrait ne pas y avoir
de grands événements dans au brésil ball
sonar ou va organiser des grandes
manifestations essentiellement à
brasilia et são paulo et rio de janeiro
où est prévu notamment un défilé navales
de l'armée un exercice de parachutisme
et donc on peut imaginer que ses
partisans vont être très mobilisés
aujourd'hui pour le bicentenaire
d'autant que le contexte est différent
de celui d'il ya un an là c'est un bol
sonar donné perdant à la future
présidentielle du 2 octobre face aux
phénix de la vie politique brésilienne
où là on va y revenir c'est lui qui va
présider les cérémonies vous parlez d'un
enterrement politique oui alors bolt le
héros il sait qu'il est dos au mur
aujourd'hui qu'il est a créé il a réussi
à récupérer une bonne partie de son
retard contre lula il était donné à 20
22 25 % via six mois à peu près
aujourd'hui il est à 37 38 % donc il
n'est plus très loin des halles ou là
mais il a vraiment un plafond de verre
puisqu'une majorité de brésiliens
aujourd'hui dix nouveautés pour lui sous
aucuns en aucun cas jamais et donc on
peut imaginer que ille en ille et envie
de faire une démonstration de force
aujourd'hui de voir d'intimider voire de
faire peur qu'est ce qui s'est passé
entre ce jour d'octobre 2010 huit jours
d'élections triomphale de celui qui
était député de rio est aujourd'hui pour
qu'il soit donné si loin dans les
sondages alors bon je me fais beaucoup
de choses et dans mon cas on peut dire
que c'est un mandat assez riche en
événements j'avais évidemment la crise
du colis de 19 qui a pesé enfin il faut
rappeler qu'il ya le brésil est le
deuxième pays le plus endeuillé au monde
par la crise du côté de 19,6 lui plus de
680 mille morts dont au moins quatre
cent mille sont attribuables directement
à l'action de le gérer bull sonar ou
ensuite ya évidemment la crise
amazonienne isolement diplomatique du
brésil et une bonne partie du brésil
hier sa triste de voir le pays dans cet
état il ya enfin et surtout la crise
économique il faut imaginer
qu'aujourd'hui au brésil il ya 33
millions de personnes qui ont faim il y
a je crois à peu près 20 millions qui
ont sombré dans l'eure dans la pauvreté
ou dans l'extrême pauvreté l'inflation
atteint des sommets depuis jamais vu
depuis 25 ans donc on est dans un pays
extrêmement tendues au niveau au niveau
social et au niveau économique et tout
ça pèse contre jérôme saunal la crise
amazonienne en ont parlé dans le journal
avec des illustrations encore tragique
de feu qui ravage la forêt ces jours ci
on voit mal on le disait comment il
pourrait renverser quand même la
tendance en quelques semaines à peine
avant la présidentielle en revanche et
c'est le sujet de votre livre bruno vous
dit qu'il serait une erreur de
considérer un bol sonar ou comme une
parenthèse dans l'histoire du brésil oui
alors ça c'est un grand danger c'est que
beaucoup de gens ont considéré que par
son extravagance ses outrances fine en
bout le scénario était marginal et qu'il
avait été élu grâce une conjoncture
favorable en 2018 et je pense que au
contraire j'irai molinaro et non
seulement le reflet d'un certain brésil
c'est à dire d'un brésil d'extrême
droite radicalisée d'un brésil qui de
plus en plus évangélique conservateur en
faveur de delà du droit avoir des armes
par exemple ou la destruction de la
nature et en même temps il est aussi un
pur produit de notre époque et de nos
démocraties je crois et c'est ça qui
doit nous inquiéter parce que bull sont
arrow est pas arrivé par hasard en 2018
grâce juste à la prison de deux lacs
étaient enfermés en prison à l'époque où
grâce à un alignement des planètes une
crise économique il a vraiment été le
produit d'une époque et notamment des
réseaux sociaux donc je sais pas si on
pourra en parler mais c'est quand même
qu'il ya investi sur sur internet et
dans les réseaux sociaux depuis très
très longtemps bien avant d'autres
politiques brésiliens et juste donner un
chiffre bolton a droit aujourd'hui
autour de 50 millions de followers comme
on dit sur les réseaux sociaux tous
réseaux sociaux compris lula qui est
l'homme politique le plus populaire du
brésil aujourd'hui tu as 15 millions
donc il faut imaginer cette différence
entre ce qu'on peut imaginer d'une
certaine marginalité de bol sonar où est
la réalité de sa popularité d'autant
moins une parenthèse et vous le rappeler
dans les pilotes du livre que rien ne
dit et ça nous rappel des épisodes
précédents malheureusement un peu plus
au nord qu'il reconnaîtra les résultats
si défaite il ya au début du mois
d'octobre il l'a dit pour moi il n'ya
que deux options la mort ou la prison il
a déjà trois heures il ya trois options
la défaite non la prison la mort ou la
défaite il a exclu il exclut la défaite
je crois à la prison ici non il faut il
vraiment imaginer que bonnart on n'a
aucune raison de reconnaître les
résultats c'est les donnait perdants ça
veut dire qu'il ya un risque de coup
d'état alors tout dépend ce qu'on
appelle un coup d'état ou coup de force
en fait le problème c'est qu'on sait pas
exactement ce que veut ball son arôme
moi j'essaie d'entrer dans sa tête dans
ce livre pour essayer de comprendre
c'est que m'inquiéterais composite qui a
plusieurs passes et qui a une longue
histoire politique et militaire et donc
on ne sait pas exactement s'il fait ça
parce qu'il veut conserver le pouvoir
quitte à le faire par la force et dans
ce cas là qu'elle soit de quel soutien
des peuples dispose-t-il ou s'il veut
rentrer en en position de force dans des
négociations pour justement ne pas finir
en prison
ouais vous dit de lui comme beaucoup
d'ailleurs deux dirigeants brésiliens
vous dit qu'il est le pire de ce qui se
fait sur la planète en termes de
populisme d'extrême droite qu'à côté de
l'huître up or bannu zemmour plus près
de nous on désert je vous cite deux pas
le socio démocrates c'est quoi le bol
son charisme
c'est évidemment une question très
difficile et c'est aussi complexe que le
personnage et c'est le produit d'un pays
très spécifique qui est le brésil c'est
pour ça que l'appellation trump
tropicale elle a des tas de raisons
d'être validée en même temps les elle
est très compliqué le bol sonar isme
c'est d'abord un extrême extrémisme
c'est ce que j'ai essayé d'expliquer
dans le livre et c'est une manière de
faire de la politique d'abord je crois
sans limite dans le langage dans les
mots dans la parole une forme de
libération d instinct je le qualifierais
comme ça le bol sonar isme et de
finalement de destruction du système
démocratique brésilien en ce qui
concerne ce pays ils incarnent les maux
qui rongent le brésil écrivez-vous
destruction effectivement l'écosystème
intolérance obscurantisme religieux
racisme quelques mois peut-être de sa
vision du monde si toutefois il y en a
une lui dont les rares voyages à
l'étranger ont été marquées par des
sorties absolue c'est une catastrophe à
chaque fois qu'ils sortent du brésil il
se sent très bien une partie des
brésiliens il sent absolument pas le
reste du monde donc à chaque fois qu'il
est sorti du brésil est une catastrophe
qui confrontent
john kerry jim carrey il a appelé la
tour de pise la tour de pizzas en fait
il est allé en chine il a dit qu'il
n'était pas dans un pays communiste donc
sa vision du monde je crois qu'elle est
très centré sur un mot sur le brésil en
fait qui implique qu'il faut imaginer
comme un géant très aimé du monde entier
très connu pour son carnaval ces
footballeurs ses plages etc mais qui
remet gens très isolée finalement parce
qu'il est coincé entre un don c'est en
atlantique et une amazonie d'une
certaine manière et donc s'impliquer
très replié sur lui-même et ball sonar
on incarne cette forme de repli vous
rappeler aussi cet épisode assez dingue
de la visite de jean yves le drian à
l'époque ministre des affaires
étrangères qui s'était fait planter pour
une visite chez le coiffeur voilà vous
avez passez donc ces trois dernières
années au brésil comment vous avez
comment vous savez ce que vous avez vu
ce pays que vous connaissez bien vous
êtes franco-brésilien changé on dit
qu'il y a ceux qu'ils aiment ce qu'ils
le détestent ball sonar ou est ce qu'il
y a quelque chose dit réconciliables
aujourd'hui on procède au brésil c'est
c'est compliqué parce que effectivement
aujourd'hui la société brezina
extrêmement polarisée je dirais pas
qu'elle ait coupé en deux parce que chez
le combo le scénariste n'est pas
homogène le clou liste ne l'est pas non
plus des tas de gens qui aiment lula
mais qui adhèrent à un certain
conservatisme sur la question des moeurs
par exemple où l'a lui-même a dit qu'il
était opposé aujourd'hui à la libération
de l'avortement au brésil donc c'est pas
comme c'est un brésil progressiste
contre un brésil conservateur mais le
problème c'est que ces deux camps sont
incarnés par des figures tellement
opposées d'une certaine manière
tellement populaire est tellement
singulière dans l'histoire du brésil
aujourd'hui
d'une irresponsabilité des deux camps ça
je crois vraiment et faut vraiment
imaginer que l'affrontement entre bôle
son art où il loue la salle
affrontements entre 30 et obama au
second tour quoi
pour comprendre qui est ball sonara
aujourd'hui vous a fallu revenir sur son
passé son enfance à trajectoire celui
qui qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le mytho
le mythe qu'est ce que vous avez appris
sur lui que vous ne saviez pas déjà qui
est important de savoir pour comprendre
qu'ils je crois qu'il ya quelque chose
qui vaut vraiment rappeler sur bolton
araud c'est un enfant de l'intérieur de
l'état de sao paulo donc ce serait
récupérée en france voilà grandi dans
une ville qui a un nom qui s'appelle
eldorado donc c'est une usine dans cette
ville de chercheurs d'or et j'ai
vraiment de l'intérieur de l'état de
sang parle de l'intérieur brésilien
s'est pas le produit des côtes et des
ville multiculturelle métissée
c'est pas le produit de rieux de ses
plages quoi et de ses charmes on va dire
c'est le produit autre chose ensuite
c'est quelqu'un qui a passé dix ans dans
l'armée ce passé militaire est
importante puisque il s'est déroulé
durant les pires années de la dictature
militaire il a été littéralement formé à
la chasse aux communistes et à certaines
méthodes de torture là on qu'ils qui
sont évidemment avec sont des références
voilà est envahie le communisme est pour
lui la mi-avril et la couleur rouge est
une obsession il est allé jusqu'à faire
changer toutes les chaises du côté de
l'aurore de la résidence officielle des
présidents brésilien pour les remplacer
par du bleu et enfants et enfin message
insiste surtout c'est le produit de 30
ans de démocratie brésilienne c'est pas
juste un militaire c'est pas juste une
personnalité que s'est construit dans
l'armée c'est d'abord quelqu'un qui
s'est construit au sein du congrès
brésilien du parlement où il a été élu
pendant 30 ans et donc ça serait
beaucoup plus agréable plus facile de le
voir comme un produit de l'armée une
sorte de caricature de capitaine latino
américains avec cigare au bec
courant dans les forêts d'amérique
latine avec une mitrailleuse son bras
mais en fait c'est d'abord un
parlementaire qui est expert dans le jeu
politique brésilien et qui joue dans
lequel ils se donnent assez bien je
voudrais qu'on parle de l'autre
personnage de votre livre le palais de
l'aurore à brasilia c'est le palais
présidentiel signé du génial architecte
brésilien oscar niemeyer la description
des pièces et surtout de ce qu'il fait
ou ce que vous pensez qu'il y fait
gerbaud leçon arrow jalonnent le
pourquoi est-ce que ce bâtiment est
important pourquoi est-ce qu'il fallait
raconter dans ce livre là c'est le sait
le premier bâtiment inauguré à brasilia
une ville sorti de nulle part à la fin
des années 50 et donc c'est vraiment une
marque d'orgueil du brésil c'est une
affirmation vis-à-vis du reste du monde
par tout un tas d'aspects déjà par son
élégance par sa symbolique la forme de
ces colonnes il ya des tas de choses à
dire malraux avait avait visité le
palais avait avait dit que c'était une
des oeuvres les plus géniales depuis
l'antiquité quoi donc c'était quelque
chose qui était très fort du point de
vue architectural et ensuite parce que
c'est un lieu tout à fait fascinant
c'est un lieu de pouvoir très ouvert
très démocratique d'une certaine manière
très beau entouré par un parc magnifique
et dans lequel vit aujourd'hui un
précédent obscurantistes paranoïaque
replie sur lui-même comme dans un bunker
et c'est cette contradiction entre gerbe
also narrow ce président très compliqué
et ce palais très ouvert très
démocratique très beau qui symbolisait
la beauté du brésil que j'ai trouvé très
intéressante à raconter pour la petite
histoire vous racontez lui qui est
complètement paranoïaque alors il faut
dire qu'il a été rappelé qu'il a été
l'objet d'un attentat qui a fait une
tuée on n'était pas bien avant voilà
pendant la campagne présidentielle de
2012 lui d'ailleurs qui l'aiment à ilham
a raconté dans son dans mon parcours
donc vous raconter qu'il reçoit dans son
dressing dans sa tenue à traditionnels
maillots de foot short way ball sonar
haut et se sent très mal à l'aise dans
ces grands espaces très ouvert parce que
c'est un palais en verre en fête est
donc évidemment il a très peur de se
faire tirer dessus et il y avait toute
une partie de son mandat où il préférait
travailler dans un dressing dans le
dressing de sa de sa chambre qui fait
quand même plusieurs dizaines de mètres
carrés donc c'est pas noël et mathieu
faisait centre des cravates et des
sous-vêtements et ils recevaient
littéralement ses plus proches à
l'intérieur de ce bunker de racing est
donc c'est une machine à fait étonnant
dans le prison d'un pays continental
d'un piqué connu plutôt comme un espace
public d'ouverture de plage etc le voir
se replier l'inter de la plus petite
pièce de ce palais ce match assez
extraordinaire je trouve et puis d'un
mot peut-être parler d'évoquer de nous
là bien sûr l'une des plus importantes
figures de la gauche latino américaine
phoenix de la vie politique brésilienne
il va y retourner au palais de l'europe
il est par grand favori mais je crois
qu'il ya vraiment quelque chose a
rappelé sur lula pour imaginer
l'importance du personnage aujourd'hui
le brésil a
la fête son bicentenaire à 200 ans sur
ses 220 il ya 50 ans de lula donc un
quart de l'histoire moderne du brésil
est incarnée par lula qui a commencé sa
carrière politique à la fin des années
70 donc le poids de lula dans l'histoire
du brésil est considérable il ya peu
d'hommes qui peuvent affirmer être le
plus important une politique de leur
pays de leur vivant et je pense qu'on
peut dire ça de lula est le deuxième
serait sans doute jamais un bol sonar
aujourd'hui donc on a vraiment un
affrontement au sommet lula part grand
favori mais il part favori avec un
certain nombre de défis à relever pour
lui et le contexte qui est celui que
vous avez rappelé merci infiniment bruno
meier feld d'être venu nous parler de ce
livre cauchemar brésilien le livre à
lire pour comprendre ce qui va se jouer
d'ici quoi trois semaines et demie au
brésil ça va être intense pour vous
merci encore on lira un coup depuis
parier